the economy is like a human body like a
roller coaster like a steam ship more
like a campfire we have got a lot of
interesting ways of describing the
economy sort of a big swirl like a
galaxy or like a big dust cloud like a
submerged beach ball maybe it's no
wonder we can't settle on a good
metaphor it's hard to measure economic
success and even now its meaning is
changing but we've come a long way from
where we started in the 1800s the us had
to rely on things like taxes on oddly
specific imports to get an idea of what
was going on during the great depression
the government realized it needed better
data to make better decisions wisconsin
senator robert lafollette pointed out
there had never been a formal study of
how much the country was making and what
it was worth his resolution helped lay
the groundwork for what became gdp after
world war ii economic success became a
story about jobs millions of americans
returned from the war looking for work
and in 1946 president truman signed a
law that made maximum employment the
responsibility of the federal government
the 1970s saw surging prices and
battling inflation became a national
obsession sometimes a crisis changes
what we value
and recently there's been another change
a new priority shaping the economic
conversation for businesses politicians
and policymakers this issue of
inequality inequality inequality this
disparity when it comes to employment
education and earnings the conversation
about economic inequality is hardly new
but in the wake of two recessions that
saw growing gaps and record wealth
concentrated in the hands of fewer
people it's found new urgency on the
national stage so now policies are
shifting towards being more inclusive
looking at sustainability
both across the us europe and china they
there's more care about the quality of
growth rather than
the number the quantity of growth the
trend is partly grounded in a growing
body of economic research with studies
looking to quantify some financial costs
of inequality and possible benefits of
overcoming it one new paper puts the
price tag at nearly 23 trillion dollars
in the u.s over the past 30 years the
gaps in labor market outcomes that we we
observe that sideline or under utilize
either way
workers can translate directly into
lower output and conversely closing
those gaps can translate into higher
economic output those economic realities
have helped policymakers refocus the
nation's priorities even the federal
reserve has said its new goal is to
strengthen employment in a way that's
broad-based and inclusive and president
biden has made reducing inequality a
centerpiece of his agenda when we lift
each other up we're all lifted up
you know the corollary is true as well
when any one of us is held down
we're all held back
more and more economic studies in recent
years have proven this
but i don't think you need economic
studies to see the truth our metrics for
success as a nation will continue to
change as they have for hundreds of
years but today the biden administration
and others say shared success is both a
moral and economic obligation and that
it will help make the us stronger and
fairer than ever before
[Music]